non la crête est d'environ
Neck Lawang Neck Alors nous sommes
c'est difficile de savoir quoi faire, c'est difficile
vraiment ah alors pendant que nous écrivions ici
juste marcher
mensonge
commerce électronique
yo yo
[Musique]
Indonésie Khoirul
RCTI
[Musique]
Le slime de Rocky et Niki est sûr et confortable
un autre sommeil
Salut, as-tu une couverture, pas de Nike
MP3
OK Google
en Indonésie
Salut Teguh pour faire une pause
[Musique]
Bonjour Madame, nous vivons dans notre propre maison
Wow, que sommes-nous censés faire avec cette nourriture
c'est tellement dommage que les personnes âgées soient encore comme ça
oui encore Wow Oh ça y est il y a des nouvelles Non
seulement nous sommes submergés Oui, généralement Bambou
Frère, soyons prudents d'abord, n'est-ce pas?
pas de vie
[Musique]
salut salut
k.h. un
[Musique]